ich höre auf und wenn ich ein solches
video hochladen dann ist das nicht
irgendeinen quatsch sondern dann wird es
diesen kanal nicht mehr so wie bisher
geben denn hier heißt es in zukunft
thanks for giving warum wieso weshalb
das erfahrt ihr in diesem video los
geht's
herzlich willkommen ja schon einmal habe
ich ein solches video gemacht hier auf
dem kanal von neun jahren hieß es hier
ich höre auf mit promi talk und ab
diesem moment war hier auch schluss den
namen habe ich damals beibehalten weiter
hieß es clixoom aber ich startete videos
mit meiner leidenschaft
wissenschaft und jetzt ist es wieder an
der zeit und zeit ist genau das richtige
stichwort vor einiger zeit erst begannen
dramatische veränderung oder ich sage
mal so wir wurden uns deren gewahrt wir
stellten fest dass es so nicht
weitergehen kann gerade hier auf klicks
um kam immer wieder die themen
klimawandel umwelt und alles in diesem
bereich die uns deutlich machten wir
sind ziemlich auf dem falschen dampfer
dem falschen weg so geht es nicht weiter
weltweit dann kam corona jetzt der
ukraine kriegt jetzt fragen sie hier
vielleicht einige was redet der da das
eine hat doch mit dem anderen überhaupt
nichts zu tun und doch all das ist vom
menschen verursacht wir menschen sind
für den schrecklichen zustand unseres
planeten und unserer gesellschaften in
vielen teilen in vielen vielen punkten
verantwortlich und da geht es nicht nur
um umwelt oder gesundheit eben sondern
auch um soziales energie missbrauch
bildung und und und und und an so vielen
ecken muss etwas getan werden wir stehen
an einer zeitenwende
und das beste ist viele viele menschen
tun etwas um etwas gutes für unsere welt
zu tun und darauf kommt es jetzt an sie
zu unterstützen denn irgendwann ist es
zu spät diese menschen zu unterstützen
ihre geschichten zu erzählen aber auch
auf missstände aufmerksam zu machen das
werdet ihr in zukunft hier auf dem kanal
sehen es wird nicht mehr darum gehen
hier irgendwie große reichweiten zu
erreichen um hunderttausende views und
viele likes oder so etwas es geht um
diese menschen die helfen die sich
engagieren die nicht opfern oder die
weil sie zu opfern wurden nicht mehr
schweigen und handeln es geht um das
gute und die guten das ist im moment
wichtig und das ist mir im moment
wichtig bestimmte themen werden hier
weiterhin auftauchen wie die energie und
verkehrswende ohne die unser planet
nicht überleben wird aber als erstes
werden wir hier die malteser mit ihrer
ukraine hilfe proud to help unterstützen
und darüber hier berichten wie es
weitergeht ehrlich gesagt ich weiß es
nicht sprich ich bin auf eure hilfe
angewiesen engagiert ihr euch
ehrenamtlich findet ihr projekt cool und
möchte dass ich darüber berichte kennt
ihr besondere menschen die hier
unbedingt vorgestellt werden sollten
schreibt mir an sieg- oder c&a adsense
for giving punkt.de und ich werde mich
darum kümmern gerne könnt ihr den kanal
auch mit einer mitgliedschaft
unterstützen das würde mich sehr freuen
und würde die arbeit etwas erleichtern
es kommt der berichterstattung über die
projekte hier zugute und sorgt damit
dafür dass sie bekannter werden die
werbeeinnahmen die dürften in zukunft
wahrscheinlich nicht so sprudeln aber
das ist auch vollkommen okay so ich
freue mich also sehr über jede
unterstützung damit ich hier über das
positive berichten kann über die
menschen die etwas bewegen wollen
allerdings eins wird bleiben bis dann
bleibt dran